[Musique]
merci beaucoup franchement je suis très
touché je sais déjà avec qui le
présenter fais-moi confiance est-ce que
tu veux présenter les Césars avec moi
ça va être une
dingue de fou j'ai déjà ma mère elle m'a
dit c'est pas possible j'ai dit signe
maman c'est possible après on peut faire
des personnages on peut faire ce que tu
veux moi ça me dérange pas je vais
réfléchir parce que pour l'instant
on ne sait toujours pas à qui Jamel
Debbouze a réellement proposé de
présenter les Césars avec lui
pardon OK
pour ça c'est pour notre entrée en duo
avec Jamel
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais là les gens ils
ont besoin de spectacle ils ont besoin
de rêver ils ont besoin de cinéma
qu'est-ce que tu as fait là excuse-moi
[Musique]
c'est avec elle que je vais présenter la
cérémonie je présente toujours la
cérémonie avec toi pour les Césars
cette année pour animer la cérémonie des
Césars le choix a été difficile alors on
les a tous pris 48e cérémonie des Césars
vendredi 24 février à 20h45 en clair en
direct et en exclusivité sur Canal+
salut Jamel c'est Jérôme Commandeur le
24 février j'anime les Césars tu me
rappelles s'il te plaît je t'embrasse
[Musique]